onward to Soul Reaver canes ancient
blade older than any of us in a thousand
times more deadly such a cool video game
weapon so onward is the new Disney Pixar
movie that I saw one trailer for movie
doesn't actually come out until next
week so maybe marketing will pick up but
I got a screening invite to this movie I
was like I saw the trailer on frozen - I
think and then never again like are they
trying to bury it why they trying to
hide it little nervous going into it I
felt like they were hiding something I
don't know so this movies about a family
made up of a mom and the two sons the
dad has been dead for a while now but
this stone can bring him back and they
get halfway done which means dad is
officially not half the man he used to
be yeah that's a dead joke on my channel
okay oh God he would say it's a dad joke
is technically a dad joke again that's -
hey you remember that one time I had the
Soul Reaver in a youtube video and I was
kind of cool among certain circles of
the internet for about two and a half
seconds see how good times let's try to
get back there all right we're moving up
so now these two brothers have to go on
this quest to complete the spell so they
can hopefully hang out with their dad
for a day to catch the stick the gimmick
is this takes place in a fairy tale land
or former fairy tale land where all the
mythical creatures have evolved into
modern society and they're basically
like uh orcs elves goblins centaurs you
know all the creatures you know from
fairy tales they're all in modern
society and they have jobs which for the
first part of this movie I was like that
just kind of feels like a shtick like
what are they doing with it I'm gonna
get the quest itself is magical but you
don't actually need a former magical
land to have a magical quest happen but
that's all I felt that first and then
things start happening in this movie
with other characters that wouldn't work
if it wasn't a former mythical lands of
I totally get it so the two brothers are
voiced by Chris Pratt and Tom Holland
Chris Pratt plays the older brother he's
the one who knows all about the lore and
his younger brothers played by Tom
Holland he's the one who doesn't know so
much about the mythology but he has a
natural knack for the magic so like two
pieces of material that go perfectly
together when linked these two brothers
they do work perfectly together not the
one who knows and you got the one who's
learning that he can do
of Chris Pratt's character I am
convinced that was going to be Jack
Black voicing that character and they
were like Oh Chris Pratt a star-lord
all right now he's voicing him and he
plays exactly he thinks he would play he
plays star-lord for sure did he remind
me of brutal legend yup totally thought
of Jack Black and in the end this is a
really enjoyable quest about two
brothers and I enjoy that big I mean I
have a brother I'm the younger brother
of two brothers so the older brother
younger brother dynamic guides it hit me
in the fields I really felt it I got
what they were saying I got where they
were going because I've always felt just
observation looking at my older brother
versus me I've always felt older
brothers just generally in life that
they have a lot of expectation on them
they're expected to be a role model for
the younger brother also they just want
to go and have fun with the friends
younger brother wants to tag along
because he wants to be cool like older
brother it's rough being an older
brother so if my brother's watching I
always appreciated that about you dude
Thanks you did good get did well now
there are Pixar movies out there Pixar
has a history there is some Pixar movies
they've been nominated for Best Picture
rightfully yourself is this gonna be one
of them probably not but on a lot of
levels the movie just hit me brother
brother dynamic check nerdy magical
quest in a mythical land check I mean
not that I've personally done that in
here I have in here I represent but the
brother brothers sentimental element
that's not the only thing the movie has
going for the movie does have a fun
premise and it has fun with it's fun
magical premise and we've just look at
the dad element that dad is a pair of
legs on this quest with them so he can't
hear anything he can't see anything so
he gets into trouble and in true Pixar
fashion they have some fun with that it
lends itself to some funny moments also
lends itself to some intense moments in
the end I enjoyed onward I felt onward
did good it has a good heartfelt family
lesson a good sibling dynamic a good
brother bonding story as it were a fun
mythical yet modern world that audiences
and families can enjoy themselves with
it entertained me it made me emotional
and in the end I want to see more from
this world so I don't let me down for a
sequel if they want to do that horror
movies have been horrendous this year
but family films a solid bet that was a
really good time no alcohol required
there was one thing that reminded me of
Shadow of the Colossus straight up I
have expected the music a copyright on
YouTube I imagine someone's gonna do it
alright onward have you seen the
trailers at all and have you seen this
movie are you gonna see this movies
reviews a little early so are you gonna
see it or what's your favorite brother
bonding go out on a quest movie whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]